hey guys welcome to the webinar I have
to tell you this a quick story I see one
of these these are called
credit card knives okay to be open like
this little piece of metal so I saw this
online the other day and it was free
plus shipping so I ordered I thought was
kind of cool because for box cutters you
know so I put it in my wallet okay
I had a seminar scheduled at something
called The Voice of America which
basically goes to Afghanistan so here
I'm going to do a seminar for to
Afghanistan on nutrition and this
happens to be in a governmental building
yeah you know what happened so don't
ever bring one of these in the
governmental agency or building so I
walk in I completely forgot about it the
police the guy the the guard basically
calls locked down you know they put me
on the wall they handcuffed me I was
like I said no now you could take it
take it uh you know take it just I'm
like what's going on here so they put me
in a room and to call the FBI yeah so
that was kind of freaked out so they
come in they're like what's the intent
I'm like I'm going to cut boxes I had no
idea that this was a my forgot about it
basically and it's weird because week
before I took this on the plane and no
one saw it so anyway that was a scare so
we're sitting in the in this room which
is a like a waiting room it's like a I
guess a snack room for some of the
government you know so I'm sitting there
and handcuffs and they had a cake
sitting right there and there's two cops
talking about nutrition and how sugars
bad for you and of course I had to chime
in and say you know that has a pretty
high glycemic index and they're talking
about being so and then I realized
they're probably not going to take
advice from someone in handcuffs so I I
kind of just waited for the FBI to come
in there and then like what's the intent
said I just thought it was cool and so
they let me go and I actually have done
doing the the seminar live are not
liable to be recorded so my wife's like
don't ever put this in your wallet ever
again so that was crazy so so today
we're going to be doing a seminar on
something called beyond weight loss so
this is going to go way beyond my lesson
I have some slides I want to show you so
let's go right to it um let me just open
my slides right here okay good
all right so you can see this right now
now here's the thing um there are people
who try to lose weight that just can't
no matter what and then other people
they don't even do barely half of what
the person is doing like a person with a
real stubborn metabolism make him lose
weight and that's really what frustrates
people so I really want to cover exactly
what you can do to bust through the
plateau but this seminar is for the
person that has tried everything and
nothing's working
we're going to go but to do that we it's
it's not about weight loss it's we have
to go beyond that and so we're going to
talk about that all right so to do that
you need to connect the dots and and I'm
talking about the relationship between
cause and effect and as you're going to
learn weight is really not the issue and
I want to first just kind of mention
like why medicine fails especially for
the endocrine system especially for
hormones you go to the doctor you do a
blood test either it shows normal and
they don't do anything or it shows
abnormal and they give you hormones so
medicine is really the management of
effects or symptoms so they really only
work on the superficial level the
surface area they don't ask why they
don't evaluate
and I'm talking about digging deeper
into the root cause
evaluation meat is a French word which
means to look so if you were to look and
keep looking at the problem you would
find out a lot of information and I'm
going to show you what what I found but
we need to ask why we need to get to the
root of the problem and medicine doesn't
do that unfortunately medicine has made
become so segmented so specialized so
overly specialized what to one part of
the body that you can't really evaluate
one part of the body without
understanding the other parts because
they all connect you've heard the
expression the hip bones connected to
the thigh bone right that is so true so
treating the cause fixes the symptom
treating the symptom does not fix the
cost and then the question is why I mean
this is a terrible statistic 98% of all
weight loss cases fail that's crazy I
mean any other area uh I don't know
fixing cars going to the moon if you had
these ratios this this track record this
percentage of failures oh my gosh that
would be terrible but with weight loss
the great majority of people fail why
because they're treating the weight
weight is a symptom and this is what you
really need to get across if you've been
to my webinars before you know about
this already but for those that never
attended you have to treat weight like a
symptom you really don't even have a
weight problem and I'm will have to give
you a t-shirt I don't have a weight
problem right on the back it's a weight
symptom it's an effect and a symptom
basically is something that indicates
something else and every time you treat
it you never get anywhere because you
either camouflage it or you continue
this symptom so what should you do if
you can't this wait well we need to
evaluate we want to go deeper we want to
find out what's behind so an evaluation
we're going to ask ask a lot of
questions
basically we're going to ask why so
that's what we're going to do right now
if you look at the different shapes of
people there's really four main shapes
that people have and based on their
shape you can get a lot of information
based on their symptoms you can get
information on what's behind the shape
yes your hormones do control where the
fat is deposited on your body but the
most common shape is the adrenal shape
and that is the person with the
midsection wait now what's unique about
the adrenal shape is that it's a
different type of fat
it's called visceral fat because
visceral means around the organs in
midsection this isn't a completely
different type of problem and um so
let's just kind of cover what the
adrenal glands on adrenal glands are
tiny glands on top of your kidney add on
top of renal kidney that react and adapt
a body to stress so they adapt your body
every part of your body to a stress
State so if you can envision you being
in stress what's going to happen to the
heart rate what's going to happen to the
salivary glands you're going to dry up
that's why when you're you do a public
speech in front of 500 people your mouth
gets real dry so you might urinate I
mean there's all these different
physiological things that happen when
you're in a stress State so let's just
go through what happens to your body if
the adrenal glands are over producing
too much hormone for too long
you get stuck in this excessive thinking
analyzing stuff solving problems 24/7
especially when you're trying to sleep
you can't sleep so you end up on the
computer and your eyes are gets strange
right you need coffee to wake up you
can't get out of bed easily you're
fixated on problems why because the
nature of the adrenal is to solve
problems so what are you doing you're
trying to survive by solving problems
silly and they're randomly becoming in
there constantly so you saw one another
one comes up so what happens in your
mind is all these problems can trigger a
lot of stress on the adrenals so it's
hard to just turn it off here's one
multitasking and someone just asked you
you you really think that multitasking
you really get more done than if you
just focus on one thing some people
think that but no it's your power is
your focus on one thing and doing one
thing at a time and so all of your
attention is on that one thing and not
on anything else multitasking really
disperses you and you really don't feel
productive and you're not productive
stress States you're kind of always in a
stress rate or straight and you're
overwhelmed libido shuts off why would a
libido shut off because when you're
being chased by a tiger you don't have
time to reproduce all those sex hormones
are blocked you get high blood pressure
think about if you're being chased by a
tiger your blood pressure tends to be
higher because of the stress state that
you're in so the person is very
dispersant we can call this a dee dee if
we want but really is an adrenal symptom
here's one asthma what why is asthma
adrenal symptom because think about what
they're treated with a bronco steroid
inhaler what our inhalers they're their
adrenal hormones so these steroids
including prednisone anything with
prednisone
you know prednisone is an
anti-inflammatory it's used for pain
it's used for allergies as you chew
asthma it's used for inflammation all
sorts of things anything that that's
used for is an adrenal problem but they
don't do anything for the adrenal
allergies our adrenal um blood sugars
this is a person on my right taking
their blood sugars why is that because
when you're during stress mode your body
is going to tap into sugar fuel and
that's why um I have people that will
eat good
but they still can't reap a lose weight
because their blood Sugar's are
constantly up and down because the
adrenal is turning your body into proton
sugar
it literally converts your muscles into
sugar yeah so one big cause of diabetes
is an adrenal so in this sense diabetes
is a symptom but but if we don't look at
it like that doing we treat it as a
disease acne is an adrenal problem
because one of the hormones produced by
the adrenal makes excess of acne sleep
apnea is an adrenal symptom snoring is
asleep is an adrenal symptom because the
the tissue in the back of the throat and
the back of the sinuses get thicker with
adrenal problems muscle cramps and your
caps in your legs is an adrenal symptom
why because the adrenals deplete your
electrolytes specifically potassium and
sodium and calcium and you get cramps
hair loss a special alopecia which is
like little pockets of hair that come
out of your head
that's an adrenal symptom - brain fog
cleaning out the brain fog is an adrenal
symptom as well because you lose your um
your memory because the high levels of
adrenal hormone called cortisol depletes
oxygen in the brain high flashes is an
adrenal because the adrenal gland backs
up the ovary during menopause and if the
adrenal gland is already tired going
into menopause you get hot flashes
cravings to specifically salty foods
chips salsa chocolate and sugar and
carbs why because the in the adrenal
state you're burning more sugar fuel
than you are fat okay loss of collagen
that shows up in loose skin underneath
the chin underneath your arm you might
see your skin gets thinned those are
adrenal symptoms
memory issues is adrenal
absent-mindedness
and loss of position and time and space
you might kind of like okay where am I
going again you know you might lose your
ability to figure out where you're going
because the adrenal will affect certain
parts of the brain
anything climbing stairs incline getting
up too fast feeling dizzy is an adrenal
symptom that's why um people when they
climb stairs they might their legs might
get heavier that's an adrenal symptom
bloating is an adrenal simply because
you lose the fluids in your and your
bile ducts in your liver and those you
lack something called bio b i le and
that bile is the thing that helps digest
especially fatty foods so you don't
digest that well so you might you eat
and you get blow-up loaded or at the end
of the day your stomach is totally
bloated you feel like you're pregnant
you in the morning it's less that's an
adrenal symptom because the gut swells
heartburn is adrenal symptom because it
produces acid reflux I mean think about
how many people are taking antacids for
this low tolerance to stress so I have a
question do you know anyone has a low
tolerance of stress friends family
neighbors they can't tolerate they get
edgy easily that isn't adrenal symptom
falling asleep after you eat lunch is an
adrenal symptom you even need for a nap
because the blood sugars are out of
whack and it'll make you tired like
after a Thanksgiving meal so check this
out I'm going to show you something this
is a book called CIPA this book is in
every single medical library book store
and this is what it looks like right
here check this out it's called by Frank
neder it's called civil cyclopædia it's
a medical Australia killest raishin for
the endocrine system so this book is
amazing because it goes it gives you
pictures and I'm showing right now all
the effects of cortisol this is a stress
hormone look at bone loss eventually
osteoporosis acne inflammation
and cysts brain fog excessive thinking
high cholesterol blood sugars acid
reflux immune factors autoimmune
diseases viruses come out of remission
asthma and then we have stretch marks
hypertension sleep problems I mean this
gland right here is pumping out fat
right into the gut as it why because
it's a survival mechanism all this
information is in this book I'm not
making these symptoms up though I want
to show you something because let me see
where I am right here I might here good
oh let me just go share it bump me out
okay so let me just go back to this okay
so you can see all these symptoms now
you get a Buffalo Hump in the upper back
osteoporosis thin-skinned moonface
that's around face all these things um
before I get it next lightest one up for
those of you that don't know me most of
you do know me my name is dr. Berg DC
that stands for District of Columbia no
I'm just kidding dr. Carr pratik
I don't do chiropractic anymore I do
nutrition functional nutrition I also
develop my own techniques manual therapy
kind of an acupressure no needles but
just manual work on the different parts
of the body relating to endocrine stress
adrenal stress that type of thing I've
been in practice 25 years my clinic is
in Northern Virginia I personally worked
on 45,000 people I taught nutrition at
Howard University as an associate
professor I also wrote a book the seven
principles of fat burning um it was the
number one best seller on Amazon trained
over 2,500 doctors and alternative
medicine so I basically trained doctors
in alternative things
I delivered over 4,900 seminars to a lot
of the governmental agencies on a
monthly basis I even I have even done
seminars to the FBI and the same
organization that came in to make sure I
wasn't a terrorist for that pocket
credit card knife I had over close to a
thousand YouTube videos and nine million
views so far and I developed the body
types but real quickly just I want to
just let you know my story I got into
this out of necessity at a desperation
because I never ate anything good until
I was like 21 22 23 years old I ate
lived on sugar Alabang Chuck my
grandmother made was the most amazing
cook and she would make these cakes for
me every birthday and I would pretty
much just keep eating
I couldn't just eat one um so I that
kind of net lasted until I was in my 20s
but little did I know at a blood sugar
issue back then I also was in wrestling
for four years and I always had to cut
weight so I would starve myself for two
or three days and eat nothing and then
pig out right before the match on the
junky submarine sandwich or a chocolate
milkshake I know it was so so stupid in
the area of health it was crazy I went
into the military and went to basic
training and by the time basic training
was done I could barely do a push-up
because my body with the stress and lack
of sleep and poor nutrition was so far
gone that I could barely pass the PT
test I mean it was crazy I mean I went I
took I went to state and wrestling and I
don't even know how I got through that
because I was exhausted and then things
kept getting worse until I had arthritis
constipation chronic fatigue syndrome a
lot of inflammation all done my spine
and this is a picture of me I think it
was 27 or 28 I was taking massive
amounts of prunes we have three kids I
had no energy for my kids it was a mess
so out of desperation I tried everything
and I was the epitome of treating
symptoms
take I was taking 94 pills 94 vitamins
to try to wake up to try to get better
but it wasn't working and so I was a
necessity found some things that work
for me and then other things and I
started to obsessively study nutrition
and the unique thing about what I did
which a lot of researchers don't do is
when I study something I don't just scan
the data I take every single word that I
don't fully understand and I look it up
in the dictionary
including the derivation where it came
from so I am digesting every piece of
information as I go and I think that's
what's different from most people who do
research is they don't go that extra
distance to really understand these
basics and how things relate um they
kind of just read through it and then
they gloss over these big words and I
found that the more you do that you're
going to be more confused so when I
study something I study it thoroughly
and that's probably one of my successful
actions of making some huge
breakthroughs as a practitioner but
anyway to make a long story short I was
28 I was very sick I got better I'm 29
now now I'm just kidding I'm 50 but I've
been working on my health and I am way
healthier than I am now than I was back
when I was 27 or 28 so it's right now as
I look at the problem back then I had
very low awareness now I have a lot of
awareness about what's going on with
people and it's about observing the
obvious and this is this is the big
thing right now that I want to talk
about the big obvious thing that I'm
saying is that medicine has switched
symptoms or effects for causes we've
making all these symptoms as diseases
and then were treating them with over
specialized doctors now I don't think
it's the medical profession doing this I
think it's the drug companies behind the
scenes that are manipulating pulling the
strings they're the puppet master they
the ones that
kind of set up the medical universities
to teach certain things the problem is
the medical profession when you're a med
student and I did pre-med you don't have
time to digest this information to
really evaluate to see if it's true or
not you have to pass the test so you're
doing a lot of memorization without
learning so you end up graduating not
really knowing the body like you should
and you don't have a chance to apply it
so you graduate as a profession that
basically manages symptoms with drugs
and that's pretty much as far as it gets
okay and then when you do that you are
not very flexible on your thinking as
far as your ability to look at other
solutions you have a lot of fixed ideas
so what they've done is they switch
these symptoms for causes and because
they sound very very scientific
you might legitimately think that it's
oh yeah that's my disease but it's
really I mean think about like just acid
reflux they have a disease now GERD it's
as the disease its gastro esophageal
reflux disorder all that means is you
get reflux some disease everything is
camouflaged as a disease even obesity
check this out last week in the American
Medical Association voted to classify
obesity as a disease in one day 78
million member American adults and 12
million American children were deemed to
have a medical condition that needs
treatment this is the drug company this
is not the medical profession somehow
they talked the AMA into doing this
probably with lobbyist group whatever
but this is what's happening they did
the same thing with cholesterol medicine
has become a business unfortunately you
know this I'm not I'm not telling you
anything you don't know you're probably
not surprised but they did it with a
cholesterol cholesterol normal values
you should be to 12 now it's 200 you're
trying to lower it down to 150 now and
basically going to get everyone on
medication and you're not going to get
off of it and you stay on it so it's
it's really bad people don't want that
they also did with the BMI body mass
index they lower that and just made
every one L piece so welcome to modern
medicine it's basically a business okay
so giving back to the adrenals coming
off my soapbox right now what's unique
about the adrenals well they are very
unique in that the adrenals do not have
an off switch if you look at the
electrical wires from the brain that
control different parts of the body
there's two systems that make up
something called the autonomic nervous
system basically it's the automatic
nervous system behind the scenes you
have the sympathetic which is what's
called the flight or fight mechanism and
then we have the parasympathetic don't
worry about the names right now but the
parasympathetic is kind of like the turn
off switch the thing that works when
you're relaxing when you're sleeping and
the sympathetics work when you're being
chased by tiger now if we look at the
little circuit board that comes out of
the spinal column from the brain look it
down here you'll see from the solar
plexus it comes right down this wire
that goes right into your adrenals
that's the on switch but guess what the
adrenals don't have any parasympathetic
control there's no off switch for the
adrenal and I found that interesting why
that's weird so what causes the adrenal
glands to get stuck on in pump out
excessive cortisol you guessed it stress
stress will do it um the other
interesting unique thing about the
adrenal and about basically about stress
in general is that there is always
stress before you start gaining weight
there's always some stress on pregnancy
stress a loss of loved one hysterectomy
tonsillitis tonsillectomy infections
loss of some severe stress change of
hormones menopause all that
basically triggers the adrenal to then
put on the weight so the waving your gut
is not just the food thing it's the
stress and here's the other thing that I
found and I found this by I have a test
that measures the autonomic nervous
system and for those of you that want to
know the name of it is called the it's a
heart called heart rate variability
technology it measures the data between
heartbeats which basically is the
nervous system that's controlling the
heart but it controls the whole body and
what you can see from this test you can
measure accumulated stress and this is
the other thing I want to talk about
your body is like a sponge it
accumulates stress and stress gets stuck
in the body so look at this first this
dial up here you see this tall dial up
here it's all the way to the right
normally it should be straight up and
down so yours I mean this person has one
that's too high that means that their
body is stuck in some stress even when
they're relaxed their body is in present
time stuck in stress but this but their
bodies are their adrenals are reacting
to old stress that stress that they had
in in the 80s and the 70s yes that is
true so your body tends to hold on the
stress very tightly here's another graph
over time when that stays too high it'll
burn out this smaller dial which is the
recovery time the recovery dial should
be all the way to the right so when you
will lose the recovery now you don't
recover to exercise stress into people
stress you become irritable people get
on your nerves especially incompetent
people especially insane people you
can't watch the news you can't watch
scary movies before bed so your your
body is very very edgy um and that is
because the adrenal system has been
burned down and so there are techniques
you can do regular techniques advanced
techniques to extract this stress and
I'm going to introduce you to something
new that I created in the last few
months since it's a membership site that
allows you to learn techniques but I'm
going to show you some things but
there's some advanced techniques that I
think you'll eventually want to learn to
pull this stress power and it's very
very effective so so let me just show
you this I want to ask you a questions I
think this sense doesn't make sense why
do these diets have in common it should
be what do these diets have in common
and I'm going to do and what do all
successful diets have in common you have
an idea here these are successful diets
Atkins low carb South Beach protein
power paleo ketogenic manifest they're
all really good diets but what do they
have in common they're lower insulin
diets they lower insulin what does that
mean it means they lower sugar so one
foundant a fundamental principle that is
very successful is you need to lower
insulin if you want to lose weight right
so you probably already know this but
you don't probably know why here's why
insulin which basically is triggered by
sugar is a dominating hormone in the
presence of a little bit of insulin all
six fat burning hormones get nullified
blocked cancelled out so it's not even a
matter of trying to trigger these
hormones it's a matter of voiding this
one hormone right here called insulin
and that's why if you just get the sugar
out of the diet you are going to lose
weight okay
so you probably already know that you
probably ever experienced that so that's
one thing but here's the other thing
that is even more fascinating
traditional diets and exercise really
don't work for belly fat this is because
belly fat is a different type of problem
and so you may have lost weight
lowering insulin but you definitely have
not lost very much belly fat with
lowering insulin with your diet because
cortisol is another hormone that is
dominating so cortisol is the dominating
hormone - and cortisol will pretty much
nullify blockout cancel all the fat
burning hormones as well so you have
these two hormones you have sugar and
stress those are the two deadly
combinations okay there is one more -
but but I'm not going to get into it but
it's estrogen if you wanted to know
estrogen will also dominate but not as
powerfully as cortisol or insulin but
here's the other interesting thing if
you cut out the sugar and you still
crave and we know the cortisol is
turning your protein your muscles into
sugar so your the adrenal hormones can
make it so your sugar is still high in
blocking fat burning from the stress why
do you think you crave sweets we under
stress so when you stress your body
needs quick energy so cortisol is a
dominating quantum so most people
mistakenly focus on trying to trigger
the papen hormones when it's a thousand
times more important to avoid the fat
dominating or fat making dominating
hormones so so it's all about avoiding
stress and about avoiding sugar right so
I'm going to give you some things to do
but I want to just mention one thing
about you know people always want to
balance their hormones that is not a
good idea why because we don't want
insulin to be too high or cortisol to be
too high we want your body is out of
balance so you can't go on a balanced
diet you can't go on a balanced hormonal
you know program you need to understand
that we want to lower insulin cortisol
and estrogen and increase the other
hormones and this whole concept of
everything in moderation is a bad idea
because all you're going to do is you're
going to maintain your fatness
and you're not going to lose weight so I
wanted to bring that point out so here's
here's what I'm going to recommend right
now I want you to focus all your efforts
only on supporting the adrenals not the
weight forget about the weight the
weight will come off as a by-product
after the adrenal body type is improved
okay does that make sense so how do we
lower cortisol I'm going to show you
some small but crucial actions these are
easy things that you can do you can
start implementing them right away and
you just need to focus on them these are
the most important things number one
thing is this sleep you must fix the
sleep out of anything if you are
sleeping and and you're not eating sugar
you're pretentious now you're going to
lose weight a lot better but if you're
not sleeping no matter what you do I
don't care if you're exercising it's not
going to work because the sleep is one
powerful thing to lower cortisol in fact
if I were just to you know weigh out
what's more important exercise or sleep
guess what it's going to be sleep
hands-down ten times more effective if
you sleep than if you exercise when but
if you don't know that you're going to
probably get up early and forget your
sleep and keep trying to burn off those
calories it's not going to work
look at these hormones you're going to
burn all the fat at night okay not
during the day so I'm going to show you
one technique that that I do let me just
kind of pull up my computer here okay so
this is a device that I use to do it
yourself device and there's it's a
tripod boom boom boom and they have
different widths okay and this is used
as a replica of my hand okay I built
this for myself
you can take it you can place it in the
back of your neck right here and you can
lean back right here and hit these
points there are two points right in the
back of your neck that if you press on
these points you can you can get some
serious improvement you can get with
your sleep you can turn off a lot of
stress you can also take your hands with
your thumbs and press over through here
and lean back and press on those points
as well and this is just a real simple
little technique that you can do that
I'm going to show you what I'm going to
recommend to be able to use this to
reduce stress okay let me come back to
my powerpoint presentation which is out
of order again okay here we go right
here now you get a tall back chair you
get a um a couch and you take the widest
points and you put it right in the back
of your right underneath your skull
there's two points there that stimulate
the off switch on the nervous system it
will create a full body relaxation
through the entire spine and you'll
sleep very deeply if you do this so this
is one little technique that I use for
stress because it's a manual technique
it's it's basically physically taking
parts of your body and pressing
different parts to release stress and
this is a very important one that I use
for sleep okay so that's one one thing
the other thing is that you your sleep
cycle starts at about 10:30 or 10:00
o'clock
10:30 you need to be in bed by like
10:15 or 10:30 to catch the first wave
if you go to sleep past well you're
pretty much screwed you will you won't
be able to catch that up because the
hormones work on these waves for ninety
minutes sleep cycles so you want to
catch the way be in the bed a little
earlier and catch that first way
and this is interesting all the benefits
of exercise occur in deep sleep all the
benefits of exercise occur in the deep
sleep about 24 to 48 hours after you
workout so when you're burning let's say
you did it to our workout and you
weighed yourself before and after it'll
be zero but if you weigh yourself the
next day or 48 hours later you weight
less because the benefit of exercise is
delayed during the exercise itself all
you're doing is you're stressing the
body out so it's all about the recovery
after that's why when you measure people
and their low recovery you have to fix
the recovery because they're not gonna
lose weight interesting number two this
is huge
uhm do people stress you out yeah
there's two types of people there's
people that bring you up and there's
people that bring you down and it's
really what a person does to your
communication do they twist what you
said do they alter what you said do the
ignore your communication do they fail
to acknowledge what you said see when
you have two people husband and wife
friends family members the goal is for
someone to say something maybe an upset
and the other person to receive that and
it's like a battery it discharges that's
that pressure that stress but if that
person is unwilling to listen as a
therapy then the person is going to
build up stress so it's really important
not to try to help people too much and
give them advice instead listening and
acknowledging and being interested is
probably the best thing you can do to
reduce stress in people but no one's
doing that they want to not listen to
the stress they don't want the person to
communicate anymore so either alter the
stress they invalidate they make the
person wrong um like the person has a
complaint that person said no no you're
just making things up or they evaluate
you know let's say you know your problem
is blah blah blah so really it
communication is
is it could be used as a tool or a
weapon and and the thing is that if
you're running into these personality
types that are doing this to you either
you can have to handle them or kind of
just avoid them because try to fix the
adrenals in this pressure cooker
environment it's really tough um so you
want to pick your friends your family
very wisely right your coworker
put your boss okay what happens when
you're under stress is you lose this one
thing called
space your space comes in on you
I mean look look what happens look at
this and look at this can you see the
space where this guy is and see the
space over here she has a lot of space
what happens when you get space is all
that stress can move off your body and
your Drina glands get happier and that's
why people can go on a vacation or go in
a different location maybe go hiking and
the stress goes way down if you go from
your office to the gym on a treadmill
and watch TV and go home that is not
good for the adrenals the best exercise
the best therapy for the adrenal is to
go somewhere to get space what workout
am i doing now basically I go outside in
my backyard and I chop wood I love doing
that it gets my attention off things I'm
lifting things I'm looking at things I
am not on a treadmill so I ride my bike
I so I always try to get space go for
long walks but the best exercise for the
dream is not a high intensity at first
they have to do long walks and just
looking at stuff not with the headphones
just getting space because look at this
here's my great graphic design here you
are thinking about all these problems
24/7 guess what you're doing you're just
triggering the adrenals because they
react to mental stress constantly so we
need to get your attention out of your
head and out into the environment
okay very important very subtle very
simple but you need to do that
number three food stresses now here's
something interesting you might think
that um you know you're a stress eater
and you eat this junk food it lowers
your stress it really doesn't
junk food does not lower stress it
increases body stress I guarantee you
eat that cake and about I'd say about I
don't know about three minutes later
four minutes later five minutes later
jörgen is field stress start building up
because your blood Sugar's have crashed
they went up in then went down and
you're getting irritable more stressed
out so these so-called junk foods
actually add more stress so it's a trap
because there's a little bit of pleasure
there it's like a drug do drugs make you
better temporarily they make you feel
better but they don't so this is a total
trap that people are in so what do you
do you avoid the sugars and the hidden
sugars so then the cravings go away and
I'm talking about fruit so fruit is not
a problem to maintain white fruit
probably won't increase weight gain but
it definitely prevents the loss of it
grains especially oatmeal breads pasta
cereal crackers biscuits waffles
pancakes those are all things that stop
weight loss yogurt even plane has the
hidden sugars it's like six to 10 grams
look start reading the label under the
sugar grams and you'll see alcohol turns
into sugar I'm sorry
but if you if you actually drink alcohol
then you're going to have to be okay
with not burning fat for one to two days
because it's going to block that burning
so just be aware of what you're doing
and be okay with it
okay so I'm just I'm just pointing your
attention on work what's making you
stressed out okay I mean look at an
apple when I look at ingredients I
always look at this one thing down here
not the total carbohydrate that the
total sugars 19 grams
that's like eating a candy bar you
should have this at zero or less than
119 grams crazy so there are things you
can eat that substitute for the things
that you crave in my membership site I
give you recipes of things like some of
these are on my website some of these
are not but this is like a healthy
granola this is a peanut butter cup this
is a bread that has no flour cookie that
has no flour no sugar ice cream there's
no sugar this is like almond joy
substitute no sugar these here you could
do these things so you keep in the
refrigerator that way you don't feel
like you're deprived and you just can do
a long-term here's another thing that's
interesting synthetic vitamin C most
vitamin C out there soul is made
synthetically from corn starch which by
the way has no vitamin C in sulfuric
acid and they mix the two together and
they make ascorbic acid and they sell it
as vitamin C well ascorbic acid is one
little tiny portion of the vitamin C
complex and if it's made artificially
it's not the real thing
so because the adrenal gland stores most
of Ottoman C in the body because you
need the vitamin C to convert into
adrenal hormones if you take synthetic C
it will deplete the other factors in the
vitamin C complex they're supposed to
make hormones and it will weaken the
adrenals so taking it like anything over
a hundred milligrams 500 milligrams of
vitamin C and your synthetic vitamins is
not a good idea for the adrenals
especially if you take grams ye I've had
people worse than adrenals by taking
synthetic vitamin C
and by the way there is no vitamin C in
orange juice why because it's
pasteurized and there's two things it's
destroyed vitamin C one is heat and the
other is oxygen so and even if you did
drink orange juice it's just like sugar
water and the reason why they can claim
it's vitamin C is because they legalized
synthetic vitamin C to be vitamin C and
so they don't really differentiate
between synthetic and whole food vitamin
C let's just take a look at vitamin C
where it and come from bell peppers oh
my gosh that's a lot of vitamin C Kiwi
kale strawberries papaya broccoli
oranges I want to just actually are low
on the vitamin C complex I like to get
my vitamin C from bell peppers or kale
all right here's the other nutrient out
of all the nutrients potassium is the
single most important nutrient for the
nervous system for the adrenals why
because when you have an overactive
adrenal you deplete your potassium and
then if you deplete your potassium you
basically you get nervous your muscles
cramp up your adrenals can't calm down
potassium is a physiological
tranquilizer it calms you down and you
need like 4700 milligrams a day no one
gets that you say well I eat a banana a
day that's 300 milligrams you'd have to
have eight bananas or
one-two-three-four-five avocados every
single day to get your potassium okay so
I recommend some other things instead of
getting that and I'm going to recommend
getting it from salad all right sell it
so let me just show you something here
check this out this is my salad okay you
need about I'd say about seven to ten
cups of salad every single day to get
your potassium but you don't just get
your potassium to get all you could
divide it and see
that's why we want to go with the
vegetables now this looks pretty big
right that's because I'm holding in
front of me but if I hold it right here
it's it's more doable say that big as my
head but look at this this is seven cups
and it's just fluffed it's not like
packed down I do 10 cups this is how
much I eat and I give them they actually
do a little bit more than this but you
need to do a minimum but look at the
type of salad I use so serious it's not
just ice berg this has a lot of
different now where do I get my salad I
go to the farmers market
why because I had a friend that lived in
Russia and I notice every time he came
to America he got fat and he a lot of
salad eat a lot of vegetables but back
home
he said his salad and his vegetables
there's there's so much more tastier
more nutritious and he loses weight on
them um because they're nutrient dense
like we have cellar that's empty
so you minimally need to go get it from
the healthy store not 7-eleven don't get
your sell it from 7-eleven or shoppers
maybe maybe they might have organic but
if you could go to the farmers market
and get your vegetables you're going to
get on much higher quality and you're
going to get you can get these mixed
lettuce leaves right here and this will
give you that healthy glow I'm 50 years
old and I know that the more of this I
eat I just I just look younger and
younger and so you want to start
consuming healthy things but most people
don't have enough vegetable in their
diet they have this little cell and
intellect vegetables you can actually
even blend this with maybe like a couple
of berries with water blend this and
make and drink your salad but you need
to start adding salads to your diet now
I also use a salad scissors now you can
see them in two knives right so I will
chop this salad right here and make it
like half of this thing so I can eat it
and if you get bloated well then have
another type of vegetable if you get
bloated like do maybe a spring green or
something like that or you need to fix
this
to be able to digest all that and I just
remembered I my wife and I make
different things every single week we
make things for the whole week that are
kind of like healthy comfort foods we
pour a granola bar without all the crap
but this week we made something called
almond bread I want to show you this
right here this is made with sesame
seeds and um onions this stuff is
freaking amazing with soy sauce but it's
organic it's Bragg's it's salty chip and
these are delicious and we made these in
a dehydrator and they're real easy so
the member should try to give you the
recipe for all these things and a lot
more and each week we create another one
but these are things that you should
prepare for the week and then that way
you don't have to think about it okay so
let me go back to the slide right here
okay so increase your potassium rich
food I don't recommend taking in a
supplement unless it's a food base it
won't create the same effect I mean when
you lose weight you wanna you want to
lose and healthily you know um now
number six only have a protein breakfast
now you're looking at my egg oil oh my
gosh that's gonna increase my
cholesterol not if you're not doing the
carbs it won't um I do grass-fed bacon
and there's nothing wrong with that at
all
in fact I'm you don't have to do it you
can do tricky bacon you don't do baking
it all but I I consume that and these
pigs are way way healthier than chicken
I'll tell you that right now because eat
grass and they it's a little bit of
different taste but that's just what I
do so you want a protein maybe some
avocado maybe some vegetable but mainly
protein fat breakfast because that's
going to actually establish your bless
you
the whole day and you will feel so much
better okay
very important for the adrenals okay so
now are you ready for some serious
results because I'm going to show you
this membership site that I basically
created over the last three months so
you really have two choices plan a you
could come to my office and let us do
the evaluation and and work on you and
that's probably the ideal scene but if
you don't live locally Plan B I created
it to do it yourself it's adrenal body
type exclusive membership and in this
membership I basically show you all the
advanced techniques on the endocrine
system it's what we do to help people
take them to the next level it's this
goes way beyond weight loss because
there is one two three four five six
different sections there's a section
called one thing at a time and basically
there are a hundred and thirty-eight
videos 98% of these videos are not on
YouTube or my website you can't find
them so it's especially created for this
portal but you start off on the left and
you go to the right and what you can do
is you can add one technique at a time
and implement it they're short to the
point videos really simple and you start
implementing one thing at a time at your
own pace and we basically show you what
to eat what not to eat help you
understand how to burn fat what to do
what not to do so that's the first
section sex the second section is called
barrier and situations and in that
section we cover something that I
surveyed 900 of my clients and people
are on my list and I the number one
thing that I found is that they can't
stick to a program because they have low
willpower well in truth it's not really
low willpower
it's that either they don't get results
or they don't have tools to overcome all
the temptation
and what to do at a restaurant what to
do in stress eating what are you bored
when you're eating out of boredom so I
take every single possible situation and
I show you how to solve it so you can
stick to things a lot longer I'm not a
lot longer I mean forever because the
next section is going to be substitute
pleasure foods and we're going to show
you amazing recipes that you can create
every single week to have in your house
to replace the junk we're getting the
junk on the trunk and replacing with
some good stuff and the you'll get the
same pleasure but without the sugar or
the bad stuff and every week I'm going
to be adding more recipes more amazing
snacks more content so this is just
going to help motivate you and keep you
going
now don't get overwhelmed by 138 videos
because um you're going to go to the
videos that pertain to you and you might
not have a problem with certain things
and that that's why I wanted to talk
about the next section which is
basically body problems solved
so if you're trying to lose weight we're
going to be able to fix all the weak
links in the body and I'm talking about
you're only as strong as your weakest
link you might have inflammation you
might have a heavy period might have hot
flashes constipation bloating sleep
problems these other note like so called
non weight related things must be fixed
in this section I show you how to fix
them I show you how to evaluate then the
next one is real-life case studies and
we up this and update this on a regular
basis the thing I like about this is
that you can watch real live examples of
my own clients in my office outside my
office and we video all the successful
actions that they have done but you'll
see one lady who lost four pounds in a
week and what we did after not losing
any weight for a long time so it's kind
of like a debug and explaining um you
know people's mistakes you can learn
from other people and how we took a lady
who are blood Sugar's were over 200 down
to 106 in one week so it's really cool
and the last one is
the most important advanced techniques I
do not recommend looking at that Ralph
that because you need to get the basics
in first but these are all the
acupressure techniques that are way
beyond just the weight loss this is
about extracting stress it's about
working on the different endocrine
glands naturally and manually you with
some of them you do need help from
another person and your spouse or a
friend or if I have family member but a
lot of them you can do on yourself um
you're also going to learn how to get
rid of old injuries and you're going to
like that so this will give you the
unfair advantage the only thing about
getting access to this membership is
that you have to agree not to teach any
of my materials okay because I'm giving
this to you added is it's an off at
discount rate and the last thing I want
to do is is have people take my
information and teach it you can use it
for yourself for your family for your
friends but you can't teach it okay
there's two people right now two doctors
that I ended up successively suing
because they did take my information and
they started teaching it without my
permission so I want to protect it
because people will alter it and you
never know and I know that's not going
to be healed but I just you're just
gonna have to agree that you won't teach
it okay two goals one is to get your
lifestyles squared away and all your
habits grooved in so you can do this
long term but then the other thing is to
get the body working right to fix the
body so you can burn more fat so this
exclusive membership you'll have access
to the advanced techniques for the Drina
body type and all others and you get
access to me personally like I answer
the questions the only thing I ask is
that like when people ask a question
sometimes they might say I can't lose
weight what do I do or they give me a
whole book of questions in their history
that's that kind of goes beyond this
this portal I'm talking like a quick
question a very specific question with
the background let's say my cholesterol
is this I've done this what do I do if
this is work
because in order to evaluate I need I
need more information but it has to be
like a quick question and answer because
that because at this level you know be
happy to just to check you know answer
any questions if they're quick and easy
not a problem and I check it daily so I
will be looking at this a lot more than
other like my blog or on the YouTube
comments
etc so you have access to me directly
of course I show you what to eat and I
show you what to do and I explain um you
know give you options for your habits
and things but I'm going to give you
strategies and then each month you will
get something really cool I have a
series of booklets that I'm working on
called beyond symptoms series and you'll
get access to that before anyone gets
access to it and each week will add more
and more things okay what is the
investment what's the cost it's not
going to be 299 bucks it's not going to
even be 199 or even 99 it's basically
only $36 a month there is a three month
minimum now you have to get three months
in advance to do this and that's because
you one month is not going to be enough
to fix all these issues you have to give
it at least three months or longer to be
able to fix these issues now there is
another option you can get it less
expensive for eighteen dollars a month
but you would have to also prepay for
the whole year okay so those are the two
options 36 or 18 a month one is the
three month minimum the next is an $18
minimum so let me just show you where
you can do this here so I think you can
this offer right here yeah I think you
can see it if not you can look below and
there should be a link but if you click
on the adrenal body type advanced
membership Add to Cart you'll be able to
go into let me see if I could I'll give
you the link to so you can go here and
choose your options I think this is
working
I don't okay should work okay let's see
here yeah it should work you should see
the link to go get this program now I
want to show you something right here we
go back to this portal right here it
bumped me out again okay let's see if I
go right here this is what I want to
share with you okay now here's the other
who's the other thing that I want to
mention if you're not a hundred percent
satisfied get a refund okay so I'm just
letting you know there's no risk to you
at all there's a 30-day money-back
guarantee if you're not totally thrilled
you can get a refund so there's no risk
so you definitely um it's a great deal
okay because here's the thing the most
important thing I think beyond the
eating and and all the other things is
the advanced techniques because it
handles the cortisol and you cannot
learn this anywhere no one's doing this
no weight loss program focuses on the
stress piece at all and there's two
other things if you want to get this
today I'm going to give you two bonuses
one is unlimited access to my meal
creator software and you'll get that for
free and it's really cool because if you
were to try to do a program and you're
trying to create a meals and you're not
you're not actually organizing or
planning out your meals for the week and
like you go day-to-day it won't work
because by Wednesday if you don't have
the right meal to the right food in your
house guess what's going to happen
you're going to go off the program so
this allows you to quickly select the
foods that you like and press enter and
create a weekly meal plan you print it
out put it on your refrigerator it also
gives you other recipes so now you have
a plan you take this to the grocery
store you can check it out and you will
have unlimited um access to this meal
crater plan and it's really cool it
allows people to stick to things a lot
easier and it's part of the bonus if you
get this thing today and there's one
more really cool bonus that I have to
share with you I've been working the
last six months on it some advanced
evaluation software and you will be able
to take this quiz once a month it's very
complex it's very deep and I wanted to
show you what it looks like hopefully I
can show you what it looks like um by
giving you let's see if I could find it
let me see right here okay
be able to show you this let me see here
hopefully yes I think hmm you gotta see
this um let's see here here's my this is
a this is the back end of software and
let me just see where it is so I'm going
to just see if you could see this here
now hmm okay that's fine I'm going to
show you okay it's not popping up here
for some reason um unfortunately but
what I did is I took every single
symptom you could imagine acne hair loss
bitching I took every single symptom and
I typed out every single possible cause
for that symptom and then I typed all
the common causes and all their symptoms
and that's the problem with evaluation
is that you have symptoms and your
causes and you know causes you know
symptoms back this can be very confusing
and I basically consolidated all this
information into some logic that I use
without even knowing I was using it I
put it together and I digitized it so
when you fill out this it's a long quiz
it will evaluate your data and find your
real cause and it tells you what to do
so it's very cool and if you were to go
ahead and take this and then each month
take it and you have less and less
symptoms you can actually get better
over time so that evaluation software is
included as a bonus if you want to get
this today
a couple questions that people always
ask me about this will this be available
later if I decide to do it later
absolutely you just won't get the
bonuses okay why do I have to do a
prepay because it takes at least three
months to be able to apply this and
actually um see some major results one
month is not going to cut it and I'm
giving you everything but the kitchen
sink I'm giving you everything in this
portal so you'll be able to learn the
advanced techniques which you might not
realize it yet but uh these are the
techniques that I help people drop their
sugars in 80 points in 30 minutes from
doing these bodywork I've had other
people get their temperature back in
this massive weight I had one lady she
um she heard I was perfect I mean it was
better than mine and she basically her
problem was she didn't sleep first
treatment we did the advanced technique
on and she slept for I think 13 hours
the next two weeks she lost more weight
in two weeks she'd she did for the last
two years from the sleep so it's about
restoring the inside of the body so you
can get your body back and whatever your
barrier is we we fix it
and the other thing is that we're going
to be adding a lot more content as we go
but it's my basically communication
portal my platform sort of speak with
you so we can go back and forth and work
on you remotely it's the best way that
do this without having to physically
come in my office you can come to my
office too and not a problem and there's
you can even come for a free evaluation
I charge for my evaluations if you want
to see me for my first evaluation so 150
but you can get an evaluation from one
of my practitioners for free okay so
that's how that works
but anyway I want to thank you so much
for your attention
in this webinar I want you to seriously
consider doing the portal and also all
the other tips that I recommend I want
you
to apply those as well because this is
the year that you need to get your body
back and do it in a healthy way and look
at the whole picture and the next time
someone comes up to you and basically
tries to stress you out now you know
exactly what they're doing with your
communication so you can start to avoid
stress with people with food with the
type of exercise you should do to
enhance your sleep and those things so I
want to thank you and I'll see you on
the inside of my portal very soon